what was uh
to you kind of the darkest moment
of what was the hardest
stumbling block to get over on the
engineer side like was there any time
where there's a doubt where it's like
i'm not sure we'll be able to do this a
kind of uh engineering challenge that
was hit do you remember anything like
that i think the one that that
my colleague at mit ray weiss worked on
so hard and
was
much more of a worry than this this is
only a question if you're not do it well
enough you have to keep making it better
somehow
but
this whole huge instrument has to be in
vacuum
and
the vacuum tanks are you know this big
around and
so it's the world's biggest high vacuum
system and the cons so how do you make
it first of all
uh how do you make this four meter long
sealed vacuum system it has to be made
out of four kilometers four kilometers
long would i say something else meters
four or four kilometers long big
difference yeah and uh so but to make it
yeah we started with uh
um a roll of stainless steel and then
we spi roll it out like a spiral so
there's a spiral weld on it
okay so
the engineering was fine we did that we
worked through
very good companies and so forth to
build it
but
the big worry
it was
what if you develop a leak
this is a high vacuum not just vacuum
system
typically in your in a laboratory if
there's a leak you put
helium around
the
the thing you have
and then you detect where the helium is
coming in but if you have something as
big as this you can't surround it with
alien so you might not actually even
know that there's a leak and it will be
affecting well we we have we can measure
the
how good the vacuum is so we can know
that but there a leak can develop and
and then we don't how do we fix it or
how do we find it
and uh so that was you asked about a
worry that was always a really big worry
uh what's the difference between a high
vacuum and uh and a vacuum what what is
high vacuum that's like some
a delta of close to vacuum is there some
threshold well there's a unit
high vacuum is uh when the vacuum and
the units that are used which are tors
there's 10 to the minus nine
there's high vacuum is usually used in
small places the biggest vacuum system
period is that cern in this big particle
accelerator but the high vacuum where
they need really good vacuum so
particles don't scatter and it is
smaller than ours so ours is a really
large uh
high vacuum system i don't know this is
so cool i mean this is basically by far
the greatest listening device
ever built by human the fact that like
descendants of apes could do this
that evolution started with single cell
organisms
i mean is there any more i'm a huge uh
theory is like yeah yeah but like
bridges when i look at bridges
from a civil engineering perspective is
one of the most beautiful creations by
human beings it's physics
you're using physics to construct
objects that can support huge amount of
mass
and it's like structural but it's also
beautiful and that humans can
collaborate to create that throughout
history and then you take this on
another level
this is this is like
is like
exciting to me beyond measure that
humans can create something so precise
but but another concept lost in this you
just said you started talking about
single cell yeah okay
you have to realize this discovery that
we made that everybody spot off on
happened
1.3 billion years ago
somewhere and then the signal came to us
1.3 billion years ago we were just
converting on the earth from single cell
to multi-cell life
so when this actually happened this
collision of two black holes yeah
we weren't here we weren't even close to
both developers there were a single
yeah we were
we're going from single cell to
multi-cell life at that point all to
meet up with this at this point yeah
wow that's like uh that's almost
romantic though
it is
uh okay so
on the human side of things
it's kind of
fascinating because you're talking about
over a thousand people team for ligo
yeah uh they started out with uh you
know around 100
and you've uh
for parts of the time at least led this
team
what does it take to lead a team like
this of incredibly brilliant
theoreticians and engineers
and just a lot of different parties
involved a lot of egos
a lot of ideas you had this fun funny
example i forget where
where in publishing a paper you have to
all agree on like
you know the phrasing of a certain
sentence or the title of the paper and
so on that's a very interesting simple
example i'd love you to speak to that
but just in general how
what does it take to lead this kind of
team
okay uh i think that the general
idea
is one we all know you want to you want
to you want to get uh
where the
the
sum of something is more than the
individual parts is what we say right
now
so that's what you're trying to achieve
yes okay how do you do that actually
mostly if we take
multiple
objects or people and when you put them
together the sum is less
yes
why because they overlap
so you don't have individual things that
you know this
person does that this person does that
then you get exactly the sum but what
you want is to develop where you get
more than what the individual
contributions are we know that's very
common people use that expression
everywhere and it's the expression that
has to be
kind of built into how people feel it's
working because if you're
part of a team
and you realize that somehow the team is
able to do more than the individuals
could do themselves than they buy on
kind of in terms of the
process so that's the
that's the goal that you have to
have is to to achieve that and that
means
that you
have to
realize
parts of what you're trying to do
that
require not that one person couldn't do
it it requires the combined talents to
be able to do something that neither of
them could do themselves and we have a
lot of that kind of thing and i think
i mean
build into the some of the examples that
i gave you
and so
uh how do you then so so the
key almost in anything you do is the
people themselves right so in our case
the first and most important was to
attract
to spend years of their life on this
and the best possible people in the
world to do it so
the only way to convince them is that
somehow it's
better and more interesting for them
than what they could do themselves
and so that's part of this
uh idea
yeah that's powerful but nevertheless
there's best people in the world there's
egos is there something to be said about
managing egos
well that's the human problem is always
the hardest and so there's that's an art
not
a science i think
uh i think the fact here that
combined there's a was a romantic goal
that we had to you know do something
that people hadn't done before which was
um
important scientifically and and a huge
challenge
uh enabled us to say take
and get uh i mean what we did just to
take an example we use the light to go
in this thing comes from lasers
we need a certain kind of laser so
the kind of laser that we use there were
three different
institutions in the world that had the
experts that do this maybe in
competition with each other
so we got all three to join together and
work with us uh to work on this as an
example so that you had uh and they had
the
thing that they were working together on
a kind of object that they wouldn't have
otherwise
and we're part of a bigger team where
they could discover something that
isn't even engineers these are engineers
that do lasers so and they're part of
our laser physicists and
so could you describe
the moment
or the period of time
when finally this incredible creation of
human beings
led to a detection of gravitational
waves
it's a long story unfortunately this is
a part that
uh we started failures along the way
kind of thing or all failures that's all
that's built into it
okay if you're not a uh if you're not
mechanical engineer
you build on your failures that's
expected so we're trying things that no
one's done before so it's technically
not just gravitational waves and so it's
built on failures
but anyway we we did
before me even the the
people did r d on the concepts
but starting in 1994 we got money from
the national science foundation to build
this thing
it took about five years to build it so
by 1999 we had
built the basic uh unit
it did not have
active seismic isolation at that stage
didn't have some other things that we
have now
what we did at that at at the beginning
was
um
stick to
technologies that we had
at least enough knowledge that we could
make work or had tested in our own
laboratories
and so then we put together the
instrument
we made it work
it didn't work very well but it worked
and
we didn't see any gravitational waves
then we figured out what limited us and
we went through this every year for
almost 10 years
never seen gravitational waves
we would
run it
looking for gravitational waves for
months
learn what limited us fix it for months
and then run it again
eventually we
knew we had to take another big step and
that's when we made several changes
including going adding these active
seismic isolation which turned out to be
a key
and we
fortunately got the national science
foundation to give us another
couple hundred
million dollars 100 million more and
we rebuilt it our fixed
or improved it
and
then in ninth uh in
2015
we turned it on
and uh
we um
almost instantly saw uh this first
collision of two black holes
um
and um then then we went through a
process of
do we believe what we've seen yeah i
think i think you're one of the people
that went through that process it sounds
like some people immediately believed it
yeah and and then you were like so as
human beings we all have different
reactions to almost anything and so
quite a few of my colleagues had a
eureka moment immediately i mean it's
this is amazing the the the figure that
we
that we put in our paper
first is just data we didn't have to go
through you know fancy computer programs
to do anything
and
and we showed next to it uh the
calculations of einstein's equations it
looks just like the what we detected wow
and we did it in two different detectors
halfway across the us so it was pretty
convincing but
but you don't want to
you don't want to fool yourself so we
had a
being a scientist
we had a for me we had to go through and
try to understand that the instrument
itself which was new i said we had
rebuild it couldn't somehow generate
things that look like this
that took some tests and then
uh the second you'll appreciate more uh
we had to somehow convince ourselves we
weren't hacked in some clever way cyber
security question yeah even though we're
not on the internet the the but yeah
no it can be physical access too yeah
that's that's fascinating
it's fascinating that you would think
about that i mean not
not enough
i mean because it's it's uh it matches
prediction
so the chances of it actually being
manipulated is very very low
but nevertheless
we still could have disgruntled all
graduate students who had worked with us
earlier that who
want you to i don't know how that's
supposed to embarrass you i suppose yeah
as i suppose i see but
but about uh what i think you said
within a month you kind of convinced
yourself in a month we convinced
ourselves uh we kept a thousand
collaborators quiet during that time
then we spent another that's funny month
or so uh
trying to understand what we'd seen
so that we could do the science with it
instead of just putting it out to the
world and let somebody else understand
that it was two black holes and what it
was the fact that a thousand
collaborators were quiet
is a really strong indication that this
is a really close-knit team yeah or and
they're around the world
or either strong
either strong knit or tight-knit or had
a strong dictatorship or something yeah
either fear or love you can rule by fear
of love yeah you can go back to mikey
valley yeah
all right well this i mean
this is really exciting that that was
that that's a success story because it
didn't have to be a success story
right
i mean eventually perhaps you could say
it'll be an event but it could have
taken it over a century to get oh yeah
yeah it's uh and um
and it's only downhill now kind of
what do you mean it's only
you mean with gravitational waves well
we're
uh well now we're off because of the
pandemic but when we turned off we were
seeing
some sort of gravitational wave event
each week
and now we're fixing we're fixing we're
adding features where it'll probably be
when we turn back on next year it'll
probably every one every couple days
and they're not all the same so it's
learning about what's out there in
gravity instead of just optics and
so it's all
uh great we're only limited by
the fantastic thing other than that this
is uh
a great field and you know it's all new
and so forth is that experimentally the
the great thing is that uh
we're limited by
technology and technical limitations not
by science
so
the the the
uh
another
a really important discovery that was
made before ours
was what's called the higgs boson made
on the big accelerator at cern you know
this huge accelerator they discovered a
really important thing it's
you know we have einstein's equation e
equals m c squared so energy makes mass
or mass can make energy and that's the
bomb
but the mechanism by which that happens
not vision but but how do you create
mass from energy
uh was never
understood
until there was a
a theory of it about 70 years ago now
and uh
so they discovered it's named after a
man named higgs it's called the higgs
boson
and so it was discovered
but since that time and i i worked on
those experiments since that time they
haven't been able to progress very much
further a little bit but not a lot
further and the difference is that we're
really lucky we're in
in what we're doing in that
there
uh you're you see this takes boson but
there's tremendous amount of other
physics that goes on and you have to
pick out the needle and the haystack
kind of of physics you can't make the
physics go away it's there
in our case we have a very weak signal
but once we get good enough to see it
the it's weak compared to where we've
reduced the background but the
background is not physics it's just
technology you know it's getting
ourselves better isolated from the earth
or getting a more powerful laser
and so each time each since 2015 when we
saw the first one we continually can
make improvements that are enabling us
to turn this into a real science to do
astronomy a new kind of astronomy it's a
little like
astronomy i mean
galileo
started the field i mean he basically
took lenses that were made for classes
and he didn't invent the first telescope
but made a telescope
looked at
neptune
and saw that it had four moons
that was the birth of
not just using your eyes to understand
what's out there
and since that time we've made better
and better telescopes obviously and
astronomy thrives
and in a similar way we're starting to
be able to
for you know crawl but we're starting to
be able to do that with
gravitational waves
and it's going to be more and more that
we can
do is we can make better and better
instruments because as i say it's not
limited by
um
picking it out of other yeah it's not
limited by the physics so you have an
optimism about engineering that event
you know as we
as human progress marches on
engineering will always uh find a way to
uh
to build a large enough device accurate
enough device to detect this as long as
it's not limited by physics yeah they'll
do it
you